I don't know could be an adventure ten
years of PLL yes you guys also just did
that reunion what was it like to
obviously not be in the same room as
everyone the question connect with
everybody yeah you know what I was so
grateful to be able to connect with them
and truly who knows maybe if it wasn't
over you know a virtual reunion we may
not have been able to all get together
at the same time so I'm actually truly
grateful that we were able to connect I
think we had about an hour prior to
going live where we got to just a bit
one another which is really nice and you
know it was great I do see crying quite
often so it's always you know nice but
for other people that I don't get to see
it was really really special to be able
to connect again we're not going to
sleep until you tell me what's in that
purse
I asked Lucy the same thing but did this
spark any conversations on your end
about a possible movie ever in the
future anything is possible at this
point like I don't rule anything out do
you ever see yourself playing Emily
fields again I would say I would never
cleaned up her if that was something
that was happening then I would jump on
board for sure absolutely
yeah do you miss me the most it was the
hardest one delay find you know the fans
love Emison yes and Sasha recently
announced that she is expecting he's
gonna be the best mom ever
oh I'm so excited
yeah I'm so excited for her have you
talked to her at all has she asked you
any questions about what motherhood is
is like so we haven't actually connected
after but we found out a little bit
before so when we were all chatting
prior to going live it was really nice
if you were all able to Sarah Congrats
and you know ask her how it's been so
I'm so excited she's gonna be so
wonderful go for a hot sip and you know
obviously I'm here if she needs anything
a diaper bag all separately um no this
is like this is the most exciting time
you know and I I'm so
yeah once this all lifts you know that
we're gonna need to see like play dates
with you I love that and Troian
it's what the fans want right and I'm
always so curious is everybody's like
did you guys plan to name your kids with
you know the initial egg and I'm like
maybe Sasha will still here [ __ ] when
you think about where you will work ten
years ago what do you remember most
about that first day on set and now that
we have talked about this show together
so many times
is there a behind-the-scenes secret that
you've never spilled that you can
finally tell us oh man is there a
behind-the-scenes secret ah okay going
on first thing I remember about my first
day of shooting was Lucy's pink
highlights because that was the first
scene and I remember that outfit that I
wore I may or may not have loved it I
remember shooting it and it was in
Vancouver so I was so grateful that we
were able to shoot there because truly
that was the only way I would have been
able to be a part of the show I'm ain't
pretending coming yet I was Canadian and
so everyone just managed to work out and
then he secret I would hide different
messages and things in my locker so you
know one of my like nicknames from my
aunt was peanut and I printed out a
peanut and I had them like I put it in
my locker so it'd be funny she'd always
be like I saw it you know where little
things like that just for people that
were watching like either photo my best
friend that was a real photo of her and
she'd be like put me in the show so
little things like that they were just
cute and fun to look back on just like
the domestic equivalent of faking an
orgasm you know they're never gonna get
better if we keep pretending I also
really like Dollface thank you how has
this pandemic sort of affected
production on on season 2 yeah I mean
it's definitely halted it so I still
don't know I don't know if anybody does
when we are going to
going back but I do look forward to that
time you know the girls are so wonderful
and I'm gonna have you know three more
hands six and nine hands people that are
gonna help out with Atlas on my fingers
and set so cat run them past there I
mean they are so wonderful it's just so
fun you know it's an easy light show
it's I get to kind of play up on the
comedy side which is fun and yeah I'm
really excited and looking forward to
going back whenever that is you know
where things could go and season two do
you have an idea I actually have no idea
and I messaged a few people few of the
writers like hey guys any thoughts um so
yeah I've only gotten a little bit in
pieces I'm sure it's gonna be great it's
all yeah so much fun with them
[Music]